the girag an experience I worked at a
record store when that corn record came
out in 1999 and um it's when I first
really got a glimpse at how [ __ ] we
are this is like a Modest Mouse record
to come out and like I told by two or
three copies of it and there's just like
droves of morons coming inside I need
that new corn record well I think we had
boxes upon boxes like [ __ ] man
we're [ __ ] and I went into the
bathroom and I was like like at the end
thinking about this in the bathroom that
that place was just covered in like
pornography not like is this like so
[ __ ] up and then the movie idiocracy
came out I was like this is [ __ ]
living in this [ __ ] already and then the
last five years have happened I was like
we're [ __ ] so deep into this [ __ ] man
so deep yeah it's happening at the same
time they're they're cracking the egg
that is artificial intelligence trying
to get that [ __ ] thing do they need
it for certain areas I went to this I
went to this rural rural County Fair
Nashville a couple weeks ago because my
wife want to take our baby to see the
little piglets and stuff so we go into
that like the 4-h kind of area and it's
cute and like you know real right real
[ __ ] who work their asses off
in there but then we go into the actual
fair part where and it is these corn
these people I sold corn records to like
20 years ago are now there and dude I
walked okay they had lemonade right
which is basically like crunchy like
crunchy lemonade there's so much sugar
in this [ __ ] like everyone's getting
like diabetes on the spot I order three
large lemonade's there's six dollars
apiece right I gave the woman a $20 bill
and she gives me back 15 bucks and
starts and starts talking to me and as
she's doing she's doing this she's like
she's like talking about [ __ ] I'm not
joking wheel of fortune
just to no one I don't like this [ __ ] oh
my god I'll show it Michelle what do i
do do I give don't correct this [ __ ]
like it's gonna be way too complicated
just take it as like take the money
don't feel guilty
oh my god embarrass her she doesn't even
know what's happening she's talking
about [ __ ] Vanna White and like [ __ ]
and I looked around like men oh there's
a lot of [ __ ] people on pills in this
country or something oh yeah
it's like then that's where I was like I
started going this rant on the way home
my baby's trying to sleep I'm like how
is Bernie Sanders talking about paying
back college loans when there's people
who don't have a middle school or high
school education I mean the these a lot
of this comes down to just [ __ ]
education you know I mean and I was like
that's a really weird way to talk about
get it you know spending tax dollars act
like is on pain back college loan well I
think it just wants a free people from
debt the the problem with college loans
is people sign up for them when you
young and dumb and you don't exactly
know what you're doing and we're getting
to a point in our life where do we hide
our citizens we knew that we needed to
drop out because we wouldn't get a
[ __ ] job from Akron University's
philosophy the point we just did we
started a band with debt
we both had debt from school we both had
that house everybody does I actually
went to this art school
they let recruiters come in in the
[ __ ] high schools it seems criminal
to me it's kind of weaselly they're
they're kind talking you into something
check it out
I went to this may be a good thing for
you I went to this school for two
quarters called the Art Institute of
Pittsburgh right and I didn't know that
it wasn't accredited I didn't know [ __ ]
they came and they recruited me and I
couldn't get into any art school I had
horrible grades in math so I tested into
like four years of remedial math it was
like I don't want to [ __ ] do that I
like photography or whatever and after
two quarters I had a teacher who just
like he went to me in the morning like a
after 10 o'clock or 10:30 class wherever
like wreaked of whiskey and he said you
I need to talk to you and he he busted
out his portfolio which is all at this
point this is like 1998 this shit's from
the mid 70s you know dusty
all the colors are faded do you want to
do this what's your life and it's book
its photographs of cupboards cabinets
yeah I had to photograph the cabinets
you get the [ __ ] out of here kid this
degrees meaningless its
you wanna [ __ ] be loading cameras
what's your [ __ ] life either you're
the only one in here that gives a [ __ ]
and I think you [ __ ] seriously think
I'm [ __ ] serious and I went home as
like dad I I think I made a mistake and
this school is a eight thousand dollars
a quarter it was [ __ ] expensive and I
oh wow and and I dropped out so then I
dropped out and I had this whole other
experience but fast forward to 2014 were
on tour we're about to go to Pittsburgh
I talking to the Pittsburgh post-gazette
they're like and I owe ya man I love
Pittsburgh from Akron two hours away I
actually used to live there I went to
this school actually it's one of the
biggest scams of all [ __ ] time and
what school MRSA Pittsburgh and it
became like local news for weeks so I
just did it I did a pretty - her
interview with the same writer a couple
weeks ago he's like hey man remember
that interview we did about you were
talking about talking [ __ ] on the artist
of history because I guess they went out
of business
and like literally they kind of hold you
accountable for it and I'm like well how
does the cause go to business
because they're scamming [ __ ] kids oh
it was a scam a lot of college is a
[ __ ] scam Wow I mean I think I know
I know I had a relative who was going to
I've paid for a lot of [ __ ] liberal
arts schools you would be surprised how
much how much I paid for I never went to
a school about family members [ __ ] I
paid for a year at Oberlin
I'm just not [ __ ] cheap you know I
should get a [ __ ] honorary degree
from this [ __ ] I paid for the ship I
don't have education I got asked to pee
I got asked to paper some of Lewis and
Clark you know and [ __ ] $60,000 here
school in Portland man and a lot there's
a school called Oberlin a liberal super
liberal arts school really cool radio
station a lot of cool people go to the
conservatory
you know Matt very liberal school and
Dan are pretty liberal [ __ ] you
know and um and it's not far from Akron
it's close so we I would drive to
Overland they had good shows there yeah
60 miles my girlfriend went there at the
time and I would go see concerts and all
kinds of [ __ ] but every time I would go
there like all these kids that were like
from New York City rich kids from New
York were never big oh man I was out
expressed an opinion about something
Inuvik man you're just a townie dude
like just a townie I'm like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like [ __ ] you who the [ __ ]
are you
you just have let your parents have a
bigger bank account than mine that's the
only difference you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I don't feel bad that you don't have a
job after you have a [ __ ] to grieve
here you [ __ ] dick so specific
serious I don't feel bad that you done
did a job after a college going to
college I think I was like what I mean I
don't know I was like fully prepared to
it when I dropped out of school if the
bike keys thing hadn't worked start a
lawn care business I don't know
wash people's [ __ ] windows I don't
really know I wasn't gonna write papers
I was gonna write academic papers I knew
that much believe it or not this is a
tour basically this is what tours you
guys do yeah
[Applause]